the ongoing protests have affected
portland shop owners with stores in the
area vandalised and looted
one of the targets was a jewelry store
that's been operating in the area for 30
years
in may protesters broke into the
premises and stole numerous items the
owner nohaka sab says clients are afraid
to go downtown because of the ongoing
protests and she spoke to rt about the
situation in portland
we're not the only ones many businesses
in downtown portland got hurt
it's not the portland we know it's not
the city that
we've been doing business in for over 30
years it it's just
boarded up streets uh uh you know a lot
of
graffiti uh just destruction everywhere
and we're
very disappointed uh with the city
officials i don't consider what they're
doing
is leadership when you feel businesses
like that when your city looks like
a war zone that's a failed leadership
and we're very disappointed
we're very angry and at this time we
just don't know what the future of
downtown portland will look like
when you allow lawlessness when you
allow
looting and when you don't hold people
accountable this stuff is gonna continue
and if the leadership failed the
businesses the residents of downtown
portland big time and that's why this is
happening there's no accountability
being held right now against looters
you